This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health and dependents. Construise a career enriching to service
of the community francophone of all the country. Don't the quality in French, it's possible
with the City. Visit Collage LaC. .A. today, An initiative of the Consortium National
of Formation in Health Supposed by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder
take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey
toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nand-es,
and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. For years, the Un-House has been presented as a monolith in mainstream media. Weedian House is a podcast that's changing the narrative. I'm Theo Henderson, and I created this show why I was Un-Housed on the streets of Los Angeles. We've grown into a two-time Webby Award-winning podcast, the only podcast that shares Un-House stories and news from the Un-House perspective. Listen to Wey and Howls on the I-Hard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course, break down the psychology of your 20s, psychology of our 20s, psychology of my 20s. You guys have no idea how long I wanted to do this episode for. Literally, this has been on my list for, I would say, three years. And I just never got around to it. I don't know why. Probably because I was like waiting for this very moment to do an episode on it.
We're talking about a really cool concept today, a little known. phenomenon called Peter Pan Syndrome. Let me start this episode with a question. Have you ever met somebody who just has no desire to grow up, who just wants to have fun all the time, seems almost like allergic to responsibility or ever getting serious about a job or a relationship who maybe is like obsessed with reliving things you did in high school as kids, reliving your uni day, despite those times being well and truly done? Do you know this person? Have you met somebody like this? This is a Peter Pan. This is Peter Pan Syndrome to a T, a pathological fear of growing up. Not growing older, that's part of it, but growing up and leaving the spontaneity, the fun, the ease,
the lack of responsibility behind. This is far more common than you may think. But because it's kind of hidden behind nostalgia or like somebody just trying to figure out their choices or somebody who is enabled by their parents, by their partners, by their friends, not a lot of people talk about it. What's sad, though, is the damage that Peter Pan syndrome does, not only to the person who is, you know, going through it and who suddenly is going to look around one day and realize that everybody else grew up but them, but also the people around them who, so deeply want this person to become an adult and show some like gusto for life that they become
more and more frustrated from trying and feel more and more kind of despondent. So this is what we're going to talk about today. If you haven't heard about it before, the psychology of Peter Pan syndrome, why some people want to stay childlike or young forever, the corresponding Wendy syndrome that we see a lot in women who date Peter Pan's, how you can be friends with this person, how you can be the partner of this person, the sibling of this person, and how much you can actually do for them? Like, can you force somebody like this to change? There is a lot to discuss, a lot to break down. It's just a fascinating episode in general, so let's get into it. So what is Peter Pan syndrome? Where did it get its name? Where did it come from?
I think a lot of us, not we all, a lot of us are familiar with the story of Peter Pan. It's like a classic childhood fairy tale, folk story. I think maybe you would call it a fairy tale, but for some revision. Peter lives on like the mysterious faraway island of Neverland. He has like this troop of like forever children called the Lost Boys. They get up to all kinds of adventures. Nothing is very difficult. They have like a nemesis, which is Captain Cook, but like he's not really a threat. Like he doesn't really ever do anything to them.
And life is just very easy. And there's no responsibilities. There's none of like the drudgery of adult life. It's all very fun. They have these adventures. And it's seemingly the fantasy of many, many people, never having to grow up and face chores and work and complex relationships, getting to be young forever. This is the very famous story from which Peter Pan syndrome emerged.
Peter Pan, the syndrome was first coined in the 80s bisychologist called Dr. Dan Kylie in his book, The Peter Pan Syndrome, men who have never grown up. And he came up with the term because he kept encountering a lot of men, a lot of older teenage boys, but mainly men who kept having all these problems with adjusting to the real world. they really struggled getting girlfriends or partners, they had trouble with their jobs, and he really believed that a lot of this derived from their fear of growing up and of being responsible. It's not an official psychological diagnosis, but the term Peter Pan syndrome gained so much popularity after his book was first published because it was kind of the first time that
anybody had dissected this particular set of behaviors and patterns, and a lot of people saw their partners saw their sons, saw themselves painfully in that description. And I think on some level, we all can kind of relate. None of us particularly enjoy paying bills. None of us particularly enjoy doing chores. Let's be real. Sometimes adulthood feels like just doing the same things over and over again to stay alive, a lot of things that aren't a lot of fun. But here's the distinction. Those with Peter Pan syndrome often exhibit those same like tendencies and behaviors and annoyances with adulthood on a pathological level. They cannot commit to a relationship, but they also really have no desire to work. And they also just want to have fun all the time. And they also seem pained by the idea
of doing chores, keeping a schedule, getting a driver's license, that sort of thing. People with the same syndrome can seem quite helpless as well. those around them might have the general impression that this person just can't get it all together. And as we said, it brings a lot of frustration. They might be prone to emotional outbursts when they are asked to do things that a normal adult would do. Or when they face stressful situations, they make a lot of excuses, they blame others for why it went wrong, why they can't do it. They find criticism difficult. They find people saying no difficult.
More broadly, they just have no desire or interest in personal growth or making solid long-term plans. They want to keep their options open. They want to have fun. They want to be spontaneous. And they can also really rely on a lot of self-destructive behaviors, you know, engaging in things like substance abuse, addictive patterns, all with the goal of escaping from and suppressing the difficult feelings that come with growing up. They want to avoid that as much
as possible through whatever means. It can happen in women, but there's a lot less accounts. I think there's very few accounts of it happening, probably because of how women are socialized to take on responsibility from a young age, in the home, in classrooms, in social groups. So why does this actually develop in a lot of, not a lot, but why does it end up developing in young guys and in men? Firstly, we need to examine the role of the people. parent. I feel like parents kind of get blamed for everything, but this is a case where it might be a little bit fair. Even if their intentions were pure, a lot of it does begin with how, and I will say men and women, but how particularly a young guy was like raised. There's this woman, Humbleina Robles Ortega.
She is a professor at the University of Granada, and she's an expert on this. She's an expert on emotional disorders, on parenting. And she basically claims that overprotecting. of parents are a massive contributor. They think they're protecting their child by limiting their independence, by always driving them everywhere, by helping them with their homework, cooking all their meals, choosing their major, not letting them get a job, but it can leave their children ill-equipped to deal with adult life. Again, they think they're doing what's best, but the child never gets the necessary skills to confront things that we all kind of have to go through as an adult, including painful things like heartbreak and scary situations and discomfort.
There's one longitudinal study from 2023 that examined the impact of having overprotective parents in thousands of children in the Netherlands. And children who had these kinds of parents were more antisocial, they had lower levels of academic achievement, poorer coping strategies, even when the parents themselves didn't think that they were being overprotective. Now, as an adult, if you have grown up in that environment, you've never adjusted. So they still may feel or feel the need to be physically and financially taken care of by their parents.
They kind of take the system for granted. And you know what? If it was me, I would probably do that. Like, I wish my parents paid all my bills. I wish they took care of everything. Of course, somebody who's always had this handed to them is going to continue. that way because not doing it is so painful, but it doesn't exactly set them up well. Now, there's a difference between an overprotective parent, like the ones we spoke about,
and a permissive parent. And permissive parents may be even worse. Overprotective parents will still say no if it is in their child's best interest. Permissive parents won't. Peter Pan syndrome can emerge because of permissive parenting, because children or this child has zero boundaries, zero restrictions on their behavior, zero punishments for following impulses that lead to poor decisions. Everything is done in permissive parenting to keep the child happy. Now this happens for a few reasons. The parent themselves may have had just a really harsh upbringing,
so they go too far in the opposite direction, kind of a form of, like it's a form of overcorrection. They may also just struggle with conflict and feeling guilty in their own relationship. including their relationship with their child, even though they obviously have authority and they still do what's best. Like, the child can be unhappy. It doesn't matter if it means they're safe and learning. That's a good thing. But they want to be loved.
They want to be seen as a nice or a good parent. That's what causes this. And sometimes permissive parenting can just be straight up neglect. Like, there's no boundaries because the parent doesn't care enough to set them. There is an entire Reddit thread about people's experiences with permissive. parenting. And it goes into so much detail on the ways that this experience, whilst probably a lot of fun in childhood, can really mess you up as an adult because you don't learn rules. You don't learn what it means to be told no. And if you only have experienced that as an adult, it's going to be
really annoying and it's going to seem really unfair. Moreover, permissive parents often, not the neglectful kind, but the I want you to love me all the time kind, they often take the blame for their children's wrongdoings, meaning their child never learns that actions have consequences, which is another important feature of growing up. I had a friend like this in school whose mom would just swoop in with an excuse for any wrongdoing and who was kind of like a mama bear figure, which power to her, but she didn't do her daughter any favors because her daughter just got her way with everything and therefore learned that she could do anything. I want to say, like, I'm not a parent.
I can't judge, and I can imagine it must be really, really hard to figure out what the right thing is for your child, especially if you had a really difficult upbringing. But these behaviours are, they're just frankly a big contributor to Peter Pan syndrome, as we see it in the research. Now, another contributor beyond parenting and that kind of relationship is fears about one's own competence. Even somebody who had the most perfectly balanced and supportive parents who also set boundaries may still develop Peter Pan syndrome because they are subconsciously, unconsciously afraid that they are not very good at being an adult and that they will fail.
Being just a person who is alive nowadays comes with a lot of expectation, right? A lot of comparison. And life is just really hard. Like it's harder to get a job. It's harder to be paid well. It's harder to be seen as competent, harder to make a mark, harder to dream big, harder to do all the things that our parents did at our age. And sometimes the psychological solution to that when we feel like that failure is all us is avoidance. You know, if I never try, I didn't fail because I wasn't capable, I failed because I wanted to. Failing was my decision because I chose not to give it a go. That's kind of the situation that they end up in. I'm not going to be a bad adult if I never force myself to act like an adult. A lot of people with Peter Pan syndrome are deeply insecure.
They're anxious, they're perfectionist, and they're kind of just scared that they won't be able to adapt or be the person that they want to be. So they mask it with this more socially acceptable facade of like, I'm just living in the moment, I'm just enjoying my youth, I'm just having fun, when really what's going on is like a deep existential fear of not feeling capable. Of course, Speaking of existential fears, the fear of growing up is also deeply correlated to the fear of aging. And I feel like a lot of us can relate to the birthday panic. Like when we were kids, we were so excited to get older. And then now it's like every birthday just feels like you're closer to dying.
And that's not a great feeling. It's easy to see why creating a psychological fantasy land of like eternal youth is attractive. After all, like society is very obsessed with youthfulness and young bodies and capable young bodies and the attractiveness of being young. When somebody lives in a fantasy land where they never have to grow up, they feel safe from what aging means. They feel safe in the delusion of being youthful, energetic, carefree. And if they can't actually freeze themselves at an age, they can freeze their behavior
at an age. Research from the 1980s, which analyzed like, I think, 1,200 retired adults in the US found that this fear of aging is really just the fear of the unknown. When someone has Peter Pan syndrome, they are gravitating towards the known. Being a child who doesn't have to assume any responsibility for whom life is always explained and taken care of for them, that is a known. and that is not as frightening as the unknowns of adulthood and the unknowns of getting older that we're facing right now. To clarify, I will say, this doesn't mean like you can't be playful and young and joyful. Like, you are still allowed to even be childlike at some points and like to be a little bit silly.
You know me, you guys have probably listened to episodes where I've just gone on and on about the importance of play psychologically and mentally and emotionally. So we're not just like throwing all of that out and saying grow up or else. However, when this bleeds into pathological childlike behaviors and irresponsibility, that is Peter Pan syndrome. That is not just having fun and being light and joyful about life. This is somebody who is paralyzed by the idea of growing up. And that has consequences for dating, for friendship, for their financial situation,
for their career, which we are going to discuss after this short break, as well as how to deal with somebody like this. Stay with us. You have the desire to help to make a real difference? The College, LaCity, you offer the program Dependance and Scenta Mental. Acquare the competences essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the difficulties of health and dependence. Construise a career enrichingance to service of the community francophone of all the Donner of the quality in French, it's possible with LaCite.
Visite Collegeslacet.C.a. A.m. A.Niciate of the Consortium National of Formation in Santee, SOTE, SOTE, SOTE, supported by SOTE Canada. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified.
There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case. your career? Yes, sir. Rape and murder a child. Just as bad as it gets.
I would think so. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevent and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not
guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the Quariad free with exclusive content. Subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby.
Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. It's a part of exciting because their new star is Javier T. Torito Hernandez.
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist?
What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa? From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends. Where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared.
All in this life has an order perfect and all is just. Wait me. I'm going to pressur me, but me will be going to be done. We are here to connect. The Chicharito. I'm Jacharito. And together with IHard Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary.
Stay close. It's a crack. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Keith Gianmanca seemed like a mild-mannered suburban dad. But secretly, he became someone else, a master of disguise who went on a crime spree.
At the time, did it seem like a crazy idea? It seemed very crazy, but I felt so desperate that I felt it was the quickest, easiest way out. Did you allow yourself to think about how it could go wrong and what that might look like? No, I didn't want to manifest that. I was trying to manifest success. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? that is not the look of an innocent man. This is going to change my life and my family dynamic forever
because everything that had existed prior in my reality is now untrue. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You know what's sad, what I think is sad, is when somebody has paid a pan syndrome, like obviously they get a really bad rap, but they miss out on the full range of emotions and experiences that life has to offer as we get older, like the richness of growing up. By remaining in like this childlike emotional and
behavioral state, the Peter Pan's of the world, miss out on like the immense satisfaction that comes with knowing you can rely on yourself and knowing that like you built this, you made this, you're responsible for the success in your life. They also miss out on the feeling of knowing that others can depend on them and that they can show up emotionally, physically, maybe even financially for their friends. Think of it this way. Like when you are experiencing a crisis, you're not going to call your Peter Pan friend. You're not going to call your friend who has no sense of adult responsibility.
That's unfortunate for you because you miss out on another support network, right? It's also responsible a bit for the Peter because I think it's a true privilege. It is. It's a privilege. It's a joy. It's a gift. Getting to support others and getting to help people through hard things and have that mutual sense of help and love and connection. It can be really frustrating to be around these people because you're moving forward. You've got ambitions. You've got plans. And they're staying still. Like they're not keeping up with the progress of life. Perhaps whilst you were listening to this, you probably thought of somebody. Right. If you've made it this far, you've got somebody in mind who fits the criteria for a Peter, I would assume,
a sibling, a romantic partner, a friend, a colleague, maybe somebody you just met in passing. And being around them is hard. It's just hard. I had a roommate like this and I actually ran into him recently, like last week. And five years on, he hasn't changed. And I remember hearing this term for the first time when we were living together and being like, bingo, like that is him that describes his behavior to a T. And seeing him five years later and being like, oh my God, you're still the same was like quite shocking. Perhaps the reason I wanted to do this episode. And the thing is, it's very easy to be resentful of Peters, especially if you're close to them, because they fail to assume responsibility for their own actions. And that's hard.
It's hard to be around somebody who like can't do simple things, like take the bins out, or wash the dishes, or show up on time, or commit. And it can be really pronounced if this person is a sibling and you see how they've been treated differently because of their behaviors or maybe even in ways that contribute to their behaviors. Like a really common example and something I'm sure many of you can relate to is like having a brother. You being a woman, you being a sister and having a brother and you can see how much is not asked of them and how much is asked of you. Like you have to have it all together. They get away with murder.
and there's always an excuse as to why they can't step up, why they can't assume responsibilities for the things that you as a sister do, or maybe you as a brother or just like anybody, like you have to grow up and they don't. And study after study shows that this dynamic in particular is like a recipe for resentment because, and it's resentment for literally everybody involved, right? Because the sibling resents the other sibling who resents the parents, who resents that sibling, who resents their parents. and like it's just this triangular motion where like everybody feels like they're hard done by
and nobody wants to take responsibility and nobody will particularly the Peter doesn't want to change. It's also hard because in those situations, if you are the sibling, you probably want to be like, can't you see how this has hurt me and how this has influenced me as an individual and like they're probably not going to listen because there's a lot of ego involved in recognizing that you are somebody who has Peter Pan Syndrome or as a parent recognizing that you are somebody who's contributed. So I think siblings of Peters get a hard rap because they just kind of have to stay silent and accept that they're never going to be and never have been treated the same way. Trying to help somebody with Peter Pan syndrome get moving or reach the level that you think
they're capable of can also make you feel like a nag. and it can make them feel really like patronized and it becomes highly personal very quickly. It's not a happy situation for anyone. Definitely hard when they're a family member, very complex when there's somebody you're dating. Whole different story. Dating, naturally, you guys know this. Like, I don't sound like I'm like mansplaining this, even though I'm a woman. But you know what I mean?
Like, I don't want to sound like, but, you know, it involves balance. It's like, yeah, you've got to accept your partner's quirks and idiosyncrasies, and you want to encourage each other to be the best version of themselves. But you also want to be able to rely on them. And if you have this recurrent feeling that your partner just like can't seem to grow up or a general feeling that they probably couldn't handle life on their own, that can really leave you questioning, like, is this relationship worth it? In a relationship setting, like, you probably notice it more.
they neglect their personal hygiene, they avoid any kind of chore, they don't really do anything around the house, they don't really do anything for their life. You might constantly be like, come on, don't you have ambitions, don't you want to do things, they might let you plan everything, they let you make big decisions, they also generally just like don't want to maybe go that extra mile in terms of being more committed. moving in with each other or getting engaged or thinking about the future. And that takes its toll. But we know about the labour load where the person who does more tours around the house often feels more exhausted and resentful, but the mental load of just having to think about what needs to get
done has the same effect. And the mental load is probably a lot more significant if you are the partner of somebody who is a peter. In the long term, right, it's hard to be with somebody when every time you bring up a plan for the future, like, there's nothing. It's hard to imagine a future with somebody who can't even take care of themselves. Like, imagine having kids with a Peter. Imagine trying to get a home loan. Imagine when things get really tough. Like, will they bolt because they can't cope with people relying on them?
Will they just go and hang out with their buddies? And how do you know that by being patient, you're not just enabling them? especially if they do have other things going on. Like they might have ADHD. They might have been through a really tough childhood. They might just be overwhelmed. Like it's a hard freaking line to walk. This is where we need to talk about Wendy syndrome,
which is the companion to Peter Pan syndrome. Peter Pan syndrome, again, normally a man doesn't want to grow up. He wants to be a boy forever, constantly reliving the glory days of his like teenage years. where he had fun and he never had to be an adult and there was no responsibility. Wendy, named after Wendy Darling, who was another character in Peter Pan, Wendy's syndrome describes the woman or the women who enable those men, who enable their boyfriend, sons, friends to be that way without even realizing it. A Wendy is empathetic, she is nurturing, she picks after Peter, she makes excuses for Peter, she often takes on a motherly role with Peter, she's
这也是彼得潘综合征的伴侣综合征。彼得潘综合征，同样，通常是指男人不想长大。他想永远做一个男孩，不断重温他青少年时期的辉煌岁月，在那里他玩得很开心，永远不必成为一个成年人，也没有任何责任。温蒂综合征以温蒂·达林的名字命名，她是《彼得·潘》中的另一个角色，它描述的是那些纵容这些男人的女性，那些纵容自己的男友、儿子、朋友保持这种状态却甚至没有意识到的女性。温蒂很有同理心，她很会照顾人，她为彼得收拾烂摊子，为彼得找借口，她经常对彼得扮演母亲的角色，她
trying her best to protect her Peter because she thinks, much like the parent, that she is helping him. It's not helping. It's keeping them in this dependent state where oftentimes they've just found somebody to replace their mother and they get the benefit of a romantic partner. There's no incentive to change there. They get the best of both worlds. The thing is, a study from the University of Granada in Spain from 2007. found that Peter Pan's, Peter Pan types, tend to gravitate towards the Wendy archetype and vice versa, because, you know, Peters are often charismatic in their chaos. They're often quite enjoyable to be around. And a Wendy often really wants to be in service to somebody else. So at first, it's like this perfect
竭尽全力保护她的彼得，因为她和父母很像，认为自己在帮助他。这根本不是在帮助。这让他们保持在一种依赖状态中，很多时候他们只是找到了可以替代母亲的人，并且还能享受伴侣带来的好处。这根本没有改变的动力。他们两全其美。问题是，根据西班牙格拉纳达大学2007年的一项研究发现，彼得潘型的人往往倾向于被温蒂原型吸引，反之亦然，因为，你知道的，彼得们在他们的混乱中通常很有魅力。他们通常非常讨人喜欢。而温蒂往往非常渴望为他人服务。所以一开始，这就像是一个完美的
match made in heaven because each person feels like they're getting something. But over time, Wendy just makes it easier for Peter to never grow up, even as she's, She believes she is helping him to grow up, and this eventually becomes exhausting. Like, the person with Wendy's syndrome will eventually realize that Peter isn't in a change. And they begin to feel taken advantage of, even though, like, the behaviors have probably been the same from the beginning. The person with Peter Pan syndrome, also we can't forget them, and they also start to feel like, why am I being lectured? Why am I being dominated? Why am I being forced to do things I don't want to do?
天作之合，因为每个人都觉得自己有所收获。但随着时间的推移，温蒂只会让彼得更轻易地永远不长大，尽管她自己认为她是在帮助他长大，而这最终会变得筋疲力尽。患有温蒂综合征的人最终会意识到彼得是不会改变的。他们开始觉得自己被利用了，尽管这些行为可能从一开始就没变过。患有彼得潘综合征的人，我们也不能忘记他们，他们也开始觉得，为什么我要被说教？为什么我要被支配？为什么我要被迫做我不想做的事？
Why is this person so demanding? And so this is often how this relationship ends. Wendy burns out, Peter Salks, and the relationship ultimately fails. But for the Peter, the cycle continues with somebody else. Again, remember, this is somebody who doesn't want to be an adult, so who doesn't want the responsibility of a committed relationship. So it's very easy for them to jump into another non-committal relationship, which is very fun and freeing and teenage-like. And it's very likely that that person they jump into the next relationship with will probably be very much like the same Wendy character they found themselves with before. So if this sounds eerily like your situation as a sibling, as a friend, as a partner,
为什么这个人这么苛求？所以这往往就是这段关系结束的方式。温蒂精疲力竭，彼得生闷气，最终关系破裂。但对彼得来说，这个循环会在另一个人身上继续。再次重申，这是一个不想长大的人，因此也不想要承诺关系的责任。所以他们很容易跳入另一段无需承诺的关系中，那非常有趣、自由且带有孩子气。而且很有可能，他们下一段关系的对象很可能和之前遇到的那个温蒂角色非常相似。所以，如果这一切听起来诡异地像你作为兄弟姐妹、朋友或伴侣的处境，
do you correct the behavior? What do you do? It's a hard question, but I don't think it's your job to fix somebody with Peter Pan syndrome, particularly if you recognize the traits of Wendy's syndrome in yourself, either as a partner or a friend or somebody else, because you will just find yourself most likely in the situation of differing interests, differing desires, differing goals and sadness. You also cannot shame somebody into changing because that builds, we know this resentment long term. It's just a really sad reality we see time and time again in like human behavior, but like people do not change for others, they change for themselves. This is like the classic theory of intrinsic motivation.
你该如何纠正这种行为？你该怎么做？这是一个艰难的问题，但我认为修复一个患有彼得潘综合征的人并不是你的工作，特别是如果你在自己身上认出了温蒂综合征的特征，无论是作为伴侣、朋友还是其他人，因为你极有可能只会让自己陷入利益不同、欲望不同、目标不同以及痛苦的境地。你也不能通过羞辱来迫使别人改变，因为我们知道，这从长远来看会滋生怨恨。这只是我们在人类行为中一次又一次看到的一种非常悲哀的现实，但人们不会为了别人而改变，他们为自己改变。这就是内在动机的经典理论。
The strongest form of motivation is what comes from within. External motivation, somebody else telling you to do something, somebody else telling you to change, just cannot be sustained no matter what people say. Like this, it's just so, it doesn't work. So what do you do? Well, you have to stop doing the things that have made their behavior and patterns easy for them. You stop taking over the responsibilities. You stop doing the adult things for them.
最强大的动机来自于内外部动机。外部动机——别人告诉你做什么，别人告诉你去改变，无论人们怎么说，都是无法持久的。就像这样，它就是行不通，不管用。所以你该怎么办？好吧，你必须停止那些让他们轻而易举维持这种行为和模式的事情。你停止包揽责任。你停止为他们做成年人该做的事。
And maybe you remove yourself and show them like, hey, if you want an adult relationship or an adult friendship or a roommate relationship even, we both need to be displaying adult behaviors and you're not. You have to make the option of being a peter difficult for them. I remember, and this is going to sound so cooked, but when I had that roommate who was definitely a peter, bless his soul, but also bless us for deal. with him. He wouldn't wash any of his plates, dishes, cups, anything. And so it got to a point where they were, like, they had molded them. And so anytime I needed to use one, I would wash it, I would use it, I would wash it again, and I would store it in a box in my room so that only I could use it, until he literally ran out of clean stuff to drink from. And he had to sheepiously be like, hey, where are all our plates and cups? Was it mature? Probably not. But did it remove the ease at which
也许你抽身离开并向他们表明，嘿，如果你想要一段成年人的恋爱关系、成年人的友谊，甚至是室友关系，我们俩都需要展现出成年人的行为，而你没有。你必须让他们选择当一个彼得变得很困难。我记得，这听起来可能有点疯狂，但当我有一个绝对是个彼得的室友时，祝他一切都好，但也保佑我们能应付得了他。他从来不洗他的任何盘子、碟子、杯子，什么都不洗。所以事情发展到了一定地步，它们甚至都发霉了。所以每当我需要用一个时，我就会把它洗干净，用完后再洗一遍，然后把它存放在我房间的一个箱子里，这样只有我能用，直到他字面意义上用光了所有干净的容器。然后他只好灰溜溜地问：嘿，我们的盘子和杯子都去哪儿了？这成熟吗？可能没有。但它是否消除了
he could literally like live like a pig and like remain childlike and dependent on us, his female roommates. Like we were his mother. Yes. And like his behavior did change. It felt weird, but it was kind of like what else do we have to do? We can't just scold him. The only way to help a peter is to make them want to help or change themselves or to leave
他像猪一样生活并保持幼稚、依赖我们（他的女性室友们）的便利性？就像我们是他的母亲一样。是的。而且他的行为确实改变了。这感觉很奇怪，但当时的情况就是除了这样还能怎么办？我们不能光是责备他。帮助一个彼得的唯一方法就是让他们想要帮助或改变自己，或者离开
them to see out their prior decision of remaining childlike and let them see the consequence of that. You can't show the consequence only through words. needs to be through change or actions. Now, obviously, if their fear of growing up is derived from anxiety around aging, not being good enough, feeling like a failure, encourage them, show them support, talk them through what they see as the worst case scenario and the other possible outcomes. Like, let's not conflate like depression or a real mental health struggle with being a peter. Like some people are struggling with responsibilities because they're in a
他们，让他们去承受自己保持幼稚的先前决定，让他们看到这带来的后果。你不能仅仅通过言语展示后果。必须通过改变或行动来体现。现在，很明显，如果他们对长大的恐惧源于对变老、不够优秀、感觉像个失败者的焦虑，那就鼓励他们，向他们表达支持，和他们一起探讨他们所认为的最坏情况以及其他可能的结果。听着，我们不要把抑郁或真正的心理健康挣扎与当一个彼得混为一谈。有些人难以承担责任是因为他们正处于一个
really tough and dark and hard place. Hence why they struggle to leave the house. Hence why they feel no sense of ambition or ability to be a committed partner or to show up. But the biggest way to differentiate that, like, is this person seriously depressed or are they a Peter? Is that Peters are otherwise quite active in ways that suit them, just not in ways that would force them to grow up? Like, they have no issue going out with friends, no issue working on, like, say, their physique, no issue holidaying. that sort of thing. They don't seem bothered or even sad by their lack of progress. They don't seem despondent. They would be happy to continue the way they are. This is what they've chosen. They want to
非常艰难、黑暗和痛苦的境地。因此他们才难以离开家。因此他们才感受不到任何雄心壮志，或者无法成为一个坚定的伴侣或给予回应。但区分这一点的最大方法——这个人是严重抑郁还是他们是个彼得——在于彼得在适合他们自己的方面其实相当活跃，只是不在那些会迫使他们长大的方面活跃？比如，他们和朋友出去玩毫无压力，锻炼体型毫无压力，度假毫无压力，诸如此类。他们似乎并没有因为自己缺乏进步而感到困扰甚至难过。他们看起来并不沮丧。他们很乐意保持现状。这就是他们选择的。他们想要
be in this state. Depress people obviously don't want to continue the way they are. They don't seem to be enjoying themselves, which sounds like the most obvious statement in the world, but like, I think it's important to clarify that there is a distinction that like there is somebody who is depressed and there's somebody who is a Peter. Let's not get them confused. Also, somebody who was young and financially insecure and a little bit directionless is also, again, not necessarily somebody with Peter Pan syndrome. Somebody with Peter Pan syndrome wants to remain where they are. They have an aversion to growing up. Somebody who's just like young and figuring things out would take the opportunity to change if it was presented to them. The Peter wouldn't. So let's finish up with
处于这种状态。抑郁的人显然不想保持现状。他们看起来并不快乐，这听起来像是世界上最显而易见的话，但我认为有必要澄清，这两者是有区别的：一个是抑郁的人，一个是彼得。我们不要把他们搞混了。同样，一个年轻、财务不稳定且有点迷茫的人，同样也不一定就是患有彼得潘综合征的人。患有彼得潘综合征的人想要留在原地。他们对长大有本能的抗拒。而一个只是年轻并在摸索的人，如果有机会改变，他们会抓住机会。但彼得不会。所以让我们用这个来做个总结
this. Do people ever ever? grow out of this? Like, is there hope for these individuals? The answer is yes. They do. People do grow out of this. There's been studies that show there's often a social turning point for the people who do change, especially around when their friends, like all the people they know start getting married, start having families of their own. And their social circle kind of shrinks and it means that the other side of things start to seem more desirable. Whether that happens at 27 or 35 or 40, who knows, but there's been additional work showing that when people realize that adult responsibility is also at times very rewarding, they also change,
。人们究竟会不会摆脱这种状态？这些人还有希望吗？答案是会的。他们确实会。人们确实会摆脱这种状态。研究表明，对于那些确实发生改变的人来说，通常会有一个社交转折点，尤其是在他们的朋友——也就是他们认识的所有人——开始结婚、开始建立自己的家庭的时候。他们的社交圈子某种程度上缩小了，这意味着另一面的生活开始显得更有吸引力。无论这是在27岁、35岁还是40岁时发生，谁知道呢，但还有更多的工作表明，当人们意识到成年人的责任有时也非常有回报时，他们也会改变，
especially when they feel like they can continue to have their fun, their joy, their childlike nature alongside this new way of living. Like, I think, sure, cleaning your house every day is really annoying. But it's also really cool that you get to live alone or that you get to keep your space exactly how you want it. Independence is pretty cool. Like having your job is most of the time, sometimes very frustrating, but so is being able to afford a travel. Items that you want. Getting to save and meet your goals is also really rewarding. Getting older doesn't just mean losing parts of yourself. It also means gaining access to new parts of yourself and new versions of yourself. So it's kind of like at some point the pro cons list shifts to the cons pros list like something flips for them
特别是当他们觉得在这种新的生活方式之外，自己还能继续拥有乐趣、快乐和童心时。比如，我认为，当然，每天打扫房间真的很烦人。但能独自居住，或者能让你的空间完全按照你想要的样子布置，这也是一件很酷的事。独立是一件挺酷的事。比如拥有工作大多数时候虽然有时令人沮丧，但能够负担得起旅行同样如此。你想要的东西。存钱并实现目标也很有回报。变老并不意味着失去一部分自我。这也意味着能够接触到新的自我和新版本的自我。所以这就有点像在某个时刻，利弊清单变成了弊利清单，某种东西在他们心中发生了翻转
and alongside that I think as well at some point again they realize you can still have fun and be an adult we did a whole episode on this the other day the psychology of whimsy like that is a big realization I think for a lot of peter's but as the saying goes like they have to realize that themselves You can take a horse to water, you can't make it drink. Somebody love, like, if they don't want to change, if they don't want to grow up, nothing you can do is going to make them. There's no forcing them. There's no arguing with it.
与之伴随的，我认为在某个时刻，他们再次意识到你仍然可以一边享受乐趣一边作为一个成年人。我们前几天刚做了一整集关于这个主题的节目——奇思妙想的心理学——我认为这对很多彼得来说是一个重大的觉醒。但俗话说得好，他们必须自己意识到这一点。你可以把马带到水边，但你不能强迫它喝水。如果某人不想改变，如果他们不想长大，你做的任何事都无法让他们改变。这是无法强迫的。这是无法通过争论解决的。
Sometimes it's just about they have to see all the things that they're also losing by staying the same. They think that they're going to lose so much by growing up. They think that that's where all the loss comes from. At some point, I think people with Peter Pan, Hand syndrome, realize all that they lose by choosing not to grow up. And as we said, there's often a social turning point. There's also, I think, an emotional turning point when they realize that their capacity and their ability to connect with others, there's a ceiling to it unless they take on some responsibility. And as the quality of their relationships get worse, and if they're
有时这仅仅在于他们必须看到自己因保持不变而失去的一切。他们以为通过长大会失去很多。他们认为所有的损失都源于此。在某个时刻，我认为患有彼得潘综合征的人会意识到他们选择不长大所失去的一切。正如我们所说，这通常是一个社交转折点。我认为还有一个情感上的转折点，当他们意识到他们与他人连接的能力和容量是有上限的，除非他们承担起一些责任。随着他们人际关系质量的恶化，如果他们是
somebody who was self-aware enough to see that they're getting worse, things will hopefully kind of start to change. Hopefully. So there you go. That is our episode on Peter Pan Syndrome. I had so much fun researching this and looking into this. It is honestly so deeply, deeply fascinating, especially Wendy's syndrome. So if you have made it this far and you're listening on Spotify, leave a little fairy emoji down below to represent Tinkerbill. And so I know that you have listened to the very end. If you know somebody who was a peter, feel free to DM me, tell me a little bit more, see if it matches up with the description. I feel like this is such an interesting concept and idea of people that's going to become a lot more popularized as we see more like
一个有足够的自我意识能够看出关系正在恶化的人，情况有望开始发生变化。希望如此。这就是全部。这就是我们关于彼得潘综合征的一期节目。我在研究和了解这个主题时玩得很开心。它真的非常非常吸引人，尤其是温蒂综合征。所以如果你听到了这里并且正在使用Spotify，请在下方留下一个微小的仙女表情符号来代表小叮当（Tinkerbell）。这样我就知道你听到了最后。如果你认识某个彼得，欢迎私信我，告诉我更多细节，看看它是否与描述相符。我觉得这是一个非常有趣的概念和想法，随着我们看到越来越多
Manosphere content and we see more increasing difficulties around like getting employment and like getting your job and like shifting gender roles. I just feel like it's going to become a much bigger part of like our social conversation. So yeah, I'm glad we could do like a full episode of it after waiting all these years. Thank you as always to our researcher Lucy Davidson who helped with this episode. She did so much fantastic research and did some really great deep diving that allowed us to make this episode what it was. What's the other thing that we need to say? Instagram, substack, Netflix, all those things in the description if you want to check them out. share this episode with a friend. Maybe somebody who you share a mutual Peter with if you think that
男权球体（manosphere）内容，以及看到就业、找工作以及性别角色转变方面日益增加的困难，它将变得更加普及。我只是觉得它将成为我们社会对话中更大的一部分。所以，很高兴在等待了这么多年后，我们能做一整期关于它的节目。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森（Lucy Davidson），她协助完成了这期节目。她做了非常棒的研究，并进行了非常深入的挖掘，才使得这期节目呈现出现在的效果。还有什么我们需要说的？Instagram、Substack、Netflix，所有这些都在简介里，如果你想去看看的话。把这期节目分享给你的朋友。也许是某个和你们共同认识某个彼得的人，如果你觉得
they would enjoy it, learn from it, laugh at it, maybe, maybe not. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Creveck and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the Iheart radio app.
他们会喜欢、从中学习并付之一笑的话，也许会，也许不会。但直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对你自己温和一点。我们很快就会再聊。那双眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变黑了。吓死我了。恶魔，醒醒吧。我是那个看到克雷维克和德皮波实施谋杀的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，被判处最高刑罚时显得无动于衷。我说，我没有罪。我要把这带进坟墓。在IHeart电台应用上收听《恶魔采石场》（The Devil's Quarry）和《骨头谷》（Bone Valley）播客。
Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential, and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your news. journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotbe. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free Iheart radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day,
苹果播客，或任何你收听播客的地方。快乐至关重要，但它也难以捉摸。不过现在，有一个全新且令人兴奋的方式来开始你的新闻之旅，迈向更快乐的存在。Joy 101。这是一个由我霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotbe）主持的新品牌播客。如果你渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且动人的直播聊天。打开免费的IHeart电台应用。搜索Joy 101并立即收听。由CVS呈现的霍达·科特比的Joy 101。每个人都视我为美式足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，
I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tornandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent. man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation. I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我仍在学习如何带着问题、错误、人际关系以及自出生以来的种种情绪生活。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的和真诚的。只是关于活着意味着什么的真诚对话。我是哈维尔·托尔纳德斯（Javier Tornandez），请在IHeart电台、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《学习做人》（Learning to Be Human）。每个家庭都有秘密。但当你发现你的父亲一直在过着双重生活时，会发生什么？那可不是一个无辜男人的神情。每个人都在对我撒谎，隐瞒他们是谁吗？我感到了绝望。我觉得这是我必须做的事。在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《深度卧底：居家男人》（Deep Cover the Family Man）。
Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority of Black City, in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里有些事本不该如此复杂，比如移除种族主义者的雕像。这里还有些事本该容易得多，比如在原地竖起一尊新雕像。我是阿凯拉·休斯（Akela Hughes），《叛逆精神》第二季就是关于这两件事的。当我看着这些雕像倒下时，我在想，我在一个黑人占多数的城市长大，而这里对奴隶主的致敬比对被奴役之人的致敬还要多，这意味着什么。在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《叛逆精神》第二季。这是一个IHeart播客。人类品质保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。